we're all made of matter right you me
that very tall building but what about
its evil twin antimatter wait does that
mean there's an antimatter rat out there
somewhere oh
I've got a physicist in an elevator
ready to explain antimatter to me in the
time it takes to go up and down that
building
[Music]
hey Karen hey all right
let's go
what is antimatter all right antimatter
is all about particles and
anti-particles so particles of matter
the stuff that you and me are made or
protons electrons things like this but
every particle in nature has kind of
like an evil twin a particle which is
the same in every way except it has the
opposite electric charge and they are
annihilate when they meet what do you
mean annihilate so you get a particle an
anti-particle when they meet they cause
a big explosion all of their Mass gets
turned into Pure Energy I thought matter
couldn't be created or destroyed though
matter can be created and destroyed but
only in equal amounts of matter and
antimatter at the same time okay I'll
just accept that yeah so this is just a
theory we've never found antimatter
absolutely not we're showered by
anti-particles all the time from outer
space these things called cosmic rays we
use antibarticles in medical imaging pet
scans okay
we're halfway through that was very very
quick they they put some kind of
material a radioactive material which is
spewing out antimatter when it meets the
norm out of your body it makes photons
and then you can image the the soft
tissue in your body how are we putting
antimatter into our bodies wouldn't that
just ex like just it does explode and
that's how we image the workings of the
organs
this is the defining characteristic of
antimatter if you get a particle an
antiparticle they meet their nylate
producing Pure Energy okay so if there
is equal amount of like every particle
has its antimatter particle twin doesn't
that mean that everything would be
destroyed because all the antimatter's
destroying its partner matter yes it
does and the fact that it doesn't happen
like that is a big problem for physical
so you don't know we don't know this is
a big problem and do we need antimatter
well it's a good job that there's none
around because we wouldn't be here but
we do need it for for doing all sorts of
things yeah
well I gotta say I am pretty glad that
uh it isn't currently destroying the
entire universe so even though it's a
physics mystery and it doesn't make
sense to me
um I'm happy thanks Kieran all right
so it goes like this there is matter in
the world subatomic particles protons
electrons you know what they are and for
every particle there is its antimatter
counterpart and this is exactly the same
except it has the opposite charge now
what happens when antimatter meets
matter is the two Collide and they get
annihilated disappear into a burst of
energy
however we're seeing less antimatter in
the universe than we are matter why is
that we don't know physics doesn't know
but hey look I'm not gonna complain
because it's probably a good thing and
the more that we can figure out how to
harness antimatter the more things we
could probably do with it maybe even one
day a Star Trek antimatter warp drive
that'd be pretty cool hey there thanks
for watching if you liked this video you
can see more elevator pitch here or you
could subscribe below for more videos
from ABC science and if you're Keen to
uncover more cosmological Mysteries then
stream Catalyst on ABC iview